romain lepers bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france pour commencer
peut-être votre première réaction après
l'annnonce du gouvernement pour les
discothèques on imagine un soulagement
de votre côté abba complètement et puis
si vous voulez c'est quelque chose que
qui est asser on va dire soudain parce
qu'on n'imaginait pas réouvrir aussi
vite après l'arrêt de 16 mois donc c'est
un soulagement et puis elle a écouté en
vue de la situation sanitaire est bon on
se dit qu clairement c'est une aubaine
pour le début de l'année 2022 alors sur
les conditions d'ouverture est ce que
vous avez des pressions on sait qu'il ya
encore énormément de cas de
contamination a su sur le territoire le
port du masque par exemple est-ce que
c'est tranché il faudra le porter ou pas
pour aller en boîte de nuit alors
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on sera obligé
encore de porter le masque pour le 16
février on n'a aucun protocole inquiet
sur arrêté concernant donc donc cette
date et c'est bien ça toute la
difficulté c'est qu'aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas comment on va on va réouvrir
dans quelles conditions donc bon on est
encore un petit peu sur sur nos talons
et puis on attend un petit peu de savoir
comment ça va se passer parce que
effectivement barreau réouvriront m'a
retrouvé nos clients on va retrouver on
va retrouver donc notre personnel mais
dans quelles conditions ça ne s'est pas
bien des discussions justement qui sont
prévues avec les
l'exécutif sur sur cette question des
conditions alors il eu des discussions
clairement sur sur les conditions de
financement et puis dead là pour ces
deux derniers mois donc pour décembre et
pour janvier mais à aucun moment on a eu
des discussions pour pour le protocole
sanitaire et c'est bien ça toute la
difficulté c'est qu'on a eu une date de
réouverture sans forcément avoir les
tenants et les aboutissants tous
concerts en tout cas ce qu'il faudra un
pass vaccinale désormais non plus un
pass sanitaires alors un test ne sera
pas
exigée selon les premières déclarations
du ministre de la santé qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
écoutez nous on est prêts on est prêt
parce que c'est quelque chose qu'on sait
faire ou le fait depuis depuis la
réouverture donc début juillet donc le 9
juillet c'est vrai que là dessus nous ça
nous pose aucun problème d'avoir ce
protocole enfin ce c'est cette méthode
d'entrée puisque puisqu'on a toujours
fait donc un contrôle pas sanitaires et
cartes d'identité ce qui est exigé
concernant le pass vaccinale la
difficulté ça a été si on avait eu un
test pcr négatif à l'entrée et ça ça a
été abandonné et tant mieux pour notre
profession alors vous le rappeliez votre
secteur a été très impacté peut-être le
plus d'ailleurs par la crise sanitaire
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous allez pouvoir
vous en sortir avec cette réouverture
annoncée
alors me concernant oui parce que c'est
un établissement qui a maintenant neuf
ans d'ancienneté donc forcément après il
est bien évident que tout le monde n'a
pas la même chance tout le monde n'est
pas dans le même secteur tout le monde
n'est pas n'a pas du tout la même la
même trésorerie peut-être donc c'est
vrai que aujourd'hui on est sous
perfusion avec les aides
comment vous dire c'est que c'est que
dans le dans le temps ou ne sait pas
trop comment on va pouvoir
retrouver nos clients retrouvent et
retrouver une habitude de sortie parce
qu'il faut savoir que quand on ouvre on
ferme eh bien il ya des habitudes qui se
prenne différemment donc on est on est
surtout dans le questionnement est de
savoir comment on commence à se passer
l'année 2022 pour nous cl il va falloir
les rembourser
faudra les rembourser quoi qu'il arrive
puisqu'il ya le remboursement du prêt
garanti par l'état qui va intervenir là
dans deux trois mois ça aussi ça fait
partie des discussions au niveau
gouvernemental
savoir si on peut pas repousser donc
l'échéance encore une fois mais repoussé
ce n'est pas
annuler ces subventions donc est bien
évident qu'il faudra les rembourser
après après voilà je crois je pense que
c'est un moment on peut demander d
exception peut-être pas un secteur
d'activité qui a été donc le plus touché
et qui a un secteur sans précédent
concernant la crise on a eu une idée du
nombre de discothèques qui ne pourront
plus rouvrir après cette crise sanitaire
en france moyens il ya un nombre qui est
aux alentours de 200 donc ce qui est
finalement énorme par rapport aux
pourcentages et discothèques en france
et c'est vrai que quand on regarde le un
peu près c'est une dizaine de pourcents
discothèque si vous regardez sur un
autre secteur d'activité comme
l'industrie si 10% des des entreprises
industrielles ne peuvent pas réouvrir
c'est quand même énorme pour le panel
économique français merci beaucoup
romain lepers gérant d'une discothèque
donc à s'affairer à nous est ce qu'il
faut aller pour vous voir à
saint-etienne vous pouvez aller au s2
voilà le rêve de ces noté merci à vous
romain lepers